and boundless landscape hobson de oro
addio nuovo prisons warner bros
pensi is a place the cure on this is us
a presto
adesso luigino dei make us haberturk
a
e una grande emozione essere qui e vi
racconto velocemente questa cosa avevo
parlato tre giorni prima di ricevere una
telefonata di partecipare il peg questo
telo e parlavo con queste persone un
giorno io voglio salire sul palco di te
di raccontare la mia storia
queste solo per dirvi che i sogni si
possono avverare quello che avete appena
visto sono gli scatti della mia fantasia
sono molto emozionata e vi ringrazio di
essere qui
ora vi voglio raccontare una favola la
mia favola in un paese molto distante da
qui viveva una piccola bambina in un
luogo chiamato favelas un luogo
dimenticato da dio quella bambina l'ha
presa per mano le ho promesso di
prendermi cura di lei
e inoltre ho preso come missione di
raccontare la sua storia a tutto il
mondo perché certe cose non devono mai
più accadere
quella bambina e oggi qui e dinanzi a
voi
si chiama monica quella bambina sono io
ho passato tutta la mia vita raccontare
la mia storia in terza persona
oggi ho deciso di essere protagonista
dei miei ricordi
spesso accade che le persone mi
domandano come si fa a diventare monica
film come si fa a diventare diventare
monica film dalla domanda anche perché
in pochissimi conoscono la storia della
mia infanzia voi conoscete alla
fotografa di successo madri di uno
splendido ragazzo che qui in sala donna
piena di sorrisi e dispense trici di
mele energia
ci tengo a dirvi però subito che la
fotografia per me è stato un percorso di
vita fondamentale non per vanità o per
successo ma per guarirmi per aiutarmi a
mettere fuori tutti i miei dolore in
modo creativo
vi voglio raccontare alcuni episodi
chiave della mia vita i quali sono stati
gli artefici della donna che sono oggi
in san paolo in brasile aveva una madre
come tutti quanti e d'altronde solo che
quella mamma forse non amava davvero i
bambini iniziamo somme dal fatto che lei
non ha mai scattato una foto a sua
figlia forse pochi lo sanno ma la
fotografia viene utilizzata in ambito
clinico terapeutico come un valido
supporto per l'affermazione della
propria identità testimone che noi
esistiamo
e di conseguenza un valido supporto per
una migliore autostima
la mia prima foto è stata scattata le
faide 17 anni da amici quando ormai
avevo deciso di abbandonare quella vita
per iniziare una nuova monti qui
presente probabilmente avrà sfogliato
naudin famiglie a prevedersi nei vari
stati dalla propria vita io no io non
sono mai esistita questa mancanza di
immagini dalla mia persona nei primi
anni nella mia vita potrebbe essere
visto da un psicologo come un valido
motivo per un gap psicologico anche
molto profondo responsabile anche di
gravi disturbi di personalità mi sembro
pazza ma tu almeno indietro dalla mia
storia
vi confesso che ho parecchi buchi neri e
se ne ricordi sono già dolorosi da
un'immagine pensare cosa la mia mente me
nasconde il primo ricordo brutto della
mia vita è stata l'età di cinque anni
con un uomo che io chiamavo papa quel
signore soffriva di una malattia
conosciutissima da tutto il mondo come
pedofilia
il primo episodio della sua malattia
aveva deciso di mettere in pratica
proprio con me anche se palla volta il
suo tentativo andò fallito perché mia
madre è rientrata in casa più presso del
dovuto il mio gentile papa però non è
riuscito a trattenere la bestia che
viveva in lui e quando avevo 8 9 anni è
riuscito a superarmi dopo vari episodi e
23 anni più tardi
lui fu arrestato denunciato e arrestato
proprio per quegli abusi e se voi
credete che i miei guai erano finiti lì
vi sbagliate di grosso
lì in poi è iniziato il mio vero e
proprio inferno
mia madre vedeva in me come una rivale
incarnava per lei la donna che aveva
rubato il suo uomo
perciò doveva essere punita disporsi di
me come sua serba torturava e seviziava
in ogni modo possibile
tanto credevo ma legava mani pierre mi
legava mani e piedi e mi chiedeva dentro
uno stanzino buio per intere giornate ma
non felice dei suoi atti aveva deciso di
fare soldi vendendo mia camionisti e
uomini malati che bussavano del mio
corpo mi mandava in giro a mendicare
e se non portavo soldi e cibo a casa mi
massacrava di botte
io ero una propria e vera associazione
ossessione per lei mi ricordo che il suo
passatempo preferito era stringermi per
gol
finché non avevo neanche più un respiro
di vita a quel momento magicamente
appariva sempre qualcuno da niente gente
strana che io chiamavo essere illuminate
mito leva dalle sue mani
nel frattempo però tutto quelle
sofferenze stava creando nei
straneffetto dentro di me perché io
chiudevo gli occhi creavo mondo
fantastico tutto mio
dove solo io ero padrone dove nessuno
poteva farmi del male
e lì ci vivevo felice quando mi era
permesso di uscire sul cortile guardava
in alto verso i cieli e mi domandavo
deve essere una vita milioni di questa è
che caspita
perché vedete sino ai miei io mi
rifiutavo profondamente di soccombere in
quel mondo
guardavo sopra gli aerei che passavano
sopra la mia testa e immaginavo di
volare via con loro gli ripetevano me
stessa come un mantra un giorno viaggerò
il mondo
parlero le lingue e la gente mi
rispetterà
credo che ognuno di noi abbia un
carattere già ben forgiato sin dai primi
anni di vita almeno penso così di me
perché mia madre quando mi imponeva di
andare fuori a mendicare
io mi rifiutavo quello suo ennesimo
abuso là fuori potevo decidere io perciò
io mingherlina 2 stecchi né per braccia
al 32 per gambe andava nei mercati
rionali e chiedevo per pochi spiccioli
alle signore se poteva aiutarli a
portare alla spesa casa dopo di che
andava nelle ville dei ricchi chiedeva
se poteva portare le spazzature fuori
oppure i cani quel gesto dava una grande
fiducia in me stessa
sapevo che era la cosa giusta quando mi
davano i soldi sapevo che quello era
giusto mi rendeva felice specialmente
per gli sguardi di approvazione che
ricevevo da coloro che mi facevano fare
qualcosa per due moneta qui e ora non è
la sede più adatta per raccontarvi tutta
la mia storia
questo episodio che avevo raccontato
sono i più leggeri assoluto immaginate
un po ma c'era un ricordo ben precisione
alla mia mente per la società
io ero un reietto avevo per loro ben
poche chance di una vita decente avevano
già deciso per me in carattere come tale
cosa dovevo essere pazza drogata labbra
prostituta assassina e così via
vi ho voluto raccontare questa queste
piccole a testimonianza perché io credo
fortemente che siamo noi il padrone i
padroni del nostro destino e vi spiego
perché molte persone al posto mio
avrebbe usato tutto quelle sofferenze
come valvole di sfogo per dare colpa a
qualcun altro avrebbe utilizzato tutto
quelli in glee ingredienti ed essere la
vittima perfetta ma io vi domando a chi
serve fare la vittima quale miglior
momento della vita al momento edificio
il buy della vita per guardarsi dentro e
trovare quella persona forte che può
ribaltare tutte le cose e cambiare la
storia
io sono testimoni io sono qui per
dimostrarvi che nessuno può dettare le
regole di quello che noi vogliamo essere
smettiamo di guardare gli altri come gli
artefici dei nostri fallimenti ogni
volta che qualcosa va storto
siamo noi i responsabili di noi stessi
siamo noi in età della ragione che
permettiamo alle persone di farci dal
torto
ricordatevi questo un bambino subisce un
adulto compie monti dico che il destino
sia già stato fissato
io non credo sia così prendiamo come
esempio l'architetto su un foglio e
traccerebbero un disegno un progetto di
una casa
ognuno di voi qui presente avrebbe
osservato quel disegno e con una forte
componente dalla propria immaginazione
avremmo immaginato la casa dei propri
sogni
a quel punto qualcuno l'avrebbe
maggiorata grande maestosa spirando
spazi magari qualcun altro una casetta
in montagna 23 animale io per esempio il
ballo in spiaggia e supponiamo che
quella architetto abbia in nome di una
divinità
per me lui ha soltanto tracciato quello
che è il nostro destino
che destino cioè la casa una base di una
casa senza sarà forte e stabile nel
tempo dipende soltanto da chi la
costruirà in parole povere quel
tracciato è tracciato del nostro destino
ma tocca a noi a farlo diventare una
fortezza indistruttibile nel tempo poi
ci siamo sempre più abituati a guardare
fuori alla ricerca della felicità ma la
felicità
da qui dentro solo noi ci conosciamo
solo noi sappiamo cosa vogliamo solo noi
conosciamo i nostri sogni più intimi ed
è proprio con questa consapevolezza che
possiamo cambiare le cose che non vanno
nelle nostre vite
oggi da oggi in poi quando uscite di qui
magari riflettete su quei stesse
cercate una persona migliore e colorate
tracciato del vostro destino nel
progetto che voi avete deciso che come
dovrà essere la vostra vita e volta
non delegata qualcuno il vostro destino
vi consiglio da oggi in poi di aprire le
spalle alzare viso fieri e forti perché
nessuno fa del torto a chi ha le spalle
larghe e il viso verso la luce nei
momenti di sconforto le cordate che
avete conosciuto una persona che ha
sofferto il peggior cosa che un essere
umano possa soffrire ed è riuscito a
tramutare tutte queste cose in qualcosa
di immenso bellissimo per diventare una
stella forte e brillante oltre alla vita
vi lascio con questo pensiero nello
sconfinato paesaggio dell'anima ci
vivono persone bellissime altro non sono
che noi stessi la fantasia è un luogo
dove curarsi da tutte le malattie dove
l'anima si rigenera ogni giorno per
renderci degli individui molto migliore
di quello che siamo
vi ringrazio vi abbraccio in grandi
ragazzi